millions of people around the world have
now been vaccinated against
covid19 but can we keep up with the
evolving virus
and will we have to vaccinate the
population for
years to come
breaking news this hour regarding the
new covid variant
variant variant variant the variant this
new
variant a big part of what the future
looks like will be determined by the
variance of the virus there are
thousands of them
circulating that's not unusual viruses
constantly make new copies of themselves
some of which will have small mutations
or changes to their genetic blueprint
a few are significant making the virus
more
infectious or harmful or helping it to
evade antibodies
and that has raised concerns about the
effectiveness of vaccines
the jabs that were designed for the
original virus
can also give protection against new
variants
but not always as much the virus will
keep mutating and evolving
and vaccines might need to be updated
but experts say that can be done
pretty quickly
i think we're going to have to get used
to the idea of
vaccinating and then re-vaccinating in
the autumn as we as we come to face
these new variants it could be that
everyone will need
boosters to make sure the population
stays protected
as the virus changes and the more
variants we see
the more likely it is that we'll need
annual jabs
we do that already for the flu bug as it
mutates every year
if we hoard vaccines and if we're not
sharing it keeps
the pandemic burning the pandemic will
not be over until the whole world's
population is protected
but many poorer countries haven't even
started immunization programs yet
they don't have the money to strike
their own vaccine deals
and don't have the infrastructure to
manufacture their own jabs
the vast majority of low-income
countries will also need vaccines that
don't need extremely cold storage
so not all of the vaccines will be
suitable
but an initiative called kovacs
supported by the world health
organization
is aiming to provide developing
countries with enough jobs
for at least 20 percent of their
populations
the big challenge is going to be making
enough vaccine for the world
that could mean 15 billion doses to
start with and with a limited number of
suitable manufacturing sites
it's likely to take several years then
there's all the booster shots on top of
that
science has brought us a range of
vaccines in astonishingly quick time
but the logistics of making and
distributing them at scale
still hasn't been cracked we need to get
more vaccine
into the arms of people because without
doubt
it is the exit strategy to the pandemic
you